okay carrying right on we we fit in
non-linear functions
we've seen polynomials we're going to
now move on to splines
which are more flexible and and
offer us a
wider scope of possibilities than
polynomials
so
we've got lots of nice built-in tools in
our for fitting splines
we're going to look at cubic splines we
need to load the package for splines
which is called splines
and and now we're ready to go
so we'll start off we'll fit a linear
model using wage again same data as we
used before
and we'll fit a cubic spline with knots
at 25 40 and 60.
okay so let's just do it and
and we'll produce the plot
okay
and we'll put in the knots so there it
is
so
let me remind you
what this means
so a spline is a cubic polynomial
because but
the function bs by default fits it gives
you a basis for cubic polynomials
you're the knots so these are
places of discontinuity
but they're just discontinuity in the
third derivative so what these are these
splines again they cubic polynomials in
each of the regions
but they constrain to be continuous at
the knots and they constrain to be have
continuous first and second derivatives
which makes them really smooth in fact
so smooth that the human eye cannot
detent detect the discontinuity there
they discontinuous in the third
derivative
so the idea of spines splines is that
they more local than polynomials
so they don't have quite the wagon tails
of of polynomials
um
and and and they're a nice way of
fitting uh flexible functions
and yeah we've actually specified where
the knots are
and in r it's really easy to do there's
a bs function which generates the basis
and there's a number of ways of of
specifying the flexible flexibility
um or
and
how you place the knots
so
once one step up from what we call fixed
knot regression splines are smoothing
splines smoothing splines are convenient
because they have essentially knots
everywhere and they control
how smooth the function is with a
roughness penalty
and here's a call to smooth dot spline
it doesn't use a formula language
it just tells it that we tell it the
predictor is age the response is wage
and here we say we want 16 degrees of
freedom
and we'll add the
the
fitted function to the plot
so 16 degrees of freedom is rather a lot
and you can see it's picked up some
wiggles here
so the this is the effective degrees of
freedoms of the smoothing spline
so it's it's allowing quite a little bit
of wiggling and it's maybe a little bit
too wiggly in this case
alternatively with smooth dot spline you
can use leave one out cross validation
to determine the smoothing parameter if
you recall in the in the text smoothing
splines had a roughness parameter which
controlled our rough the function was
and
here we contr in this first chord we
controlled it by by specifying the
effective degrees of freedom and the
roughness penalty was was chosen
accordingly
here we're going to use
we're going to tell it to use cross
validation to pick the tuning parameter
or the roughness parameter
and so there we go it was a little
warning from smooth dot spline that
noticed that there were a lot of
ties in x
but it turns out that's fine for our
purposes and and so there's nothing to
be concerned about
and we'll include
that fitted function well they all look
the same you have to really zoom in if
you want to see any difference says the
one with the with that smoothing spline
uh produced
had less effective degrees of freedom it
says 6.79
remember the effective degrees of
freedom don't have to be an integer it's
a heuristic for for how rough the
function is
in this case about
six to seven degrees of freedom
our fixed knot regression spline
um
let's see where is it
um that's in fit
no we've overwritten fit let's see how
many degrees of freedom in this one
we'll we'll refit it
and and we'll do
summary of foot
and
we can just count the parameters
and we see there's one two three four
five six parameters so it's got six
degrees of freedom so with four knots
um it ended up with six degrees of
freedom
and uh
the smoothing spline
using a slightly different methodology
ended up with just over six degrees of
freedom
okay
well the final topic is going to be
generalized additive models
we really want to fit
a model with just one single predictor
we usually have more than one predictor
so we need a way of mixing these
together and also producing nice plots
and the gam package is going to help us
do that
so again we require gam
so the gam package is loaded
and again we'll use the the wage data
and here we'll fit a generalized
additive model
so
we call gam we tell it the response is
wage and here we tell it we want a
smooth term in age with four degrees of
freedom a smooth term in year with four
degrees of freedom
education is a factor variable so we
just say we'll have education in as
linear terms it'll make
dummy variables for each of the levels
and fit constants and we tell it the
data is wage
now
this
s is is a special function known to gam
and what it tells gam is it wants a
smoothing spline in the variable age
with four degrees of freedom and
likewise for this term over here and
these two terms are going to be fit
jointly
and we'll see
when we produce the plot
so before we plot we'll set up a plot in
grid
where we want
three columns
and this may be a little squashed let's
see and um
i'll first plot it and see
yeah it's a little squashed so let's
just
squash it down
a little bit so the plot looks a little
bit more balanced
still
we can squash it down a bit further
no that's
is it yeah there we go
and
what this plot function's done is
produce a plot for each of the terms in
the gam
and plotted those terms plus the
standard errors for each of those terms
so this is the shape we've been seeing
for for the variable age in in all the
univariate plots but now we've got year
as well as education included as well
and so we see that salaries tends to
increase with with here
there seems to be in a dip around 2005
but then continued to rise
and no big surprise
salary increases monotonically with
education
now
because we've limited in plot space here
normally the plot for a factor variable
like this would indicate at the top of
the plot each of what each of the levels
are but there's no room for that and so
it's
it's only ended up putting the lowest
one but these are the levels of of age
and they monotone in
in
in in the amount of education
so this is a very
convenient so this was done using
plot.gam
so this is a very convenient um
[Music]
way of fitting nonlinear functions in
several variables and having nice ways
of producing plots
gam also works for logistic regression
and other kinds of generalized linear
models so here we'll use our binary
variable for wage
and we'll fit the term smooth term in
age and the smooth term in year
and so we do that
and
we can plot that gam as well
oh plus education and we plot that game
as well we left off the standard errors
here because i happen to know that some
of them are really wide
and they would have dwarfed the plots
and so this is plotting the
contributions to the logit of of the
probability
each as the separate functions since the
the model is additive in those
so you can use in gamm you can do some
tests so let's see if we need a
non-linear term for the variable year
so we'll fit another gam where instead
of having a smooth term in here we'll
just have a linear term in here the rest
is the same we'll call that gam2a
and now we can use anova to test those
two models and
it gives you the two models and it does
the test and the chi squares
the p-value is 0.82 which says we really
don't need this non-linear term
for
year a linear term will be fine you can
in fact
test further and see if you need a term
at all for you
so we've seen gam knows how to plot
functions nicely it turns out you can
use the plot method from gam to plot
models even fit by lm and glm
and so we'll demonstrate that now
so here we'll fit a linear model
again with wages as a response but
instead of using gam we'll just fit lm
and we'll generate a spline basis
using
our other spline function which is ns
which remembers to we had natural
splines and ns gives us a basis in
natural splines so we want a natural
spline in age
and here we specify instead of the knots
we specify the effective degrees of
freedom so this looks very similar to
the call to gam except we're using a
fixed basis a reduced set of basis
functions to represent the splines
and
and likewise for year
and
and then plus a linear term in education
so we fit that model and now even though
it's an lm we can use the plot method
for gam now
since lm is not of class gam we need to
write out plot.gam to specify that we
want to use the that particular plot
method
and we plot that function and
it does a similar thing to what it did
for a legitimate gam
object it plots a fitted function
and and it's included the standard
errors
so that's just a glimpse of the of the
capability of the gam function
have a look at the help files for gam
there's there's documents on on gam rob
and i actually have a book a
1991 book on generalized additive models
you can find out lots more details and
there's various papers have been written
on gams and um
to and you can also look in um in
in the chapter in in
this introduction to statistical
learning to learn a little bit about
games and see what the capabilities are